e non mi ricordo una sola cosa l'accordo
ecco com'era
ci sta riprovando
perché lo faccio come sono
stabili al prezzo di avvisarli non se
n'è accorto
perché dice cosa interessante guglielmo
devi aprire il blog questa mattina non
l'hai aperto perché avevi erin
dormiglione con la faccia niente
ero già sul lavoro e mentre di cercare
in tutti i modi di rubare i segreti tuo
fratello che per la prima volta vede in
un contesto vino più istituzionale
perché tu mi ha visto sempre a casa ma
non ha mai pensato
certo poi guidato artina nome sulla nuca
ok però ap il blog blog numero 18 questi
così una pista molto largo cui ci stiamo
lavorando
regale nel percorso di professionisti se
poi la mia offerta è sempre valida la
tua offerta
niente pieno
allora guglielmo com'è la vita sul set
vero ma è fatta di sacrificio enrico hai
presente come si scrivono
mai nella mia vita un grande è che
torniamo a casa mi manca quel delirio
latemar cast a dormire
13 in quell'ora
ma non ti manca quella cappa mancherò
curdo e cosi e lega
[Musica]
murdoch è mancata fortuna chalker
mammamia guardo poco oggi è quanto è
dormire è svegliato di un gonfiore pero
si osservi una faccia che adesso non
entrava nell'inquadratura
ora però non credete a nulla di ciò che
vivo guglielmi gay non parte questo
ormai l'ho detto a ruba
ed è anche un competente sul suo canale
non sa fare il suo lavoro ma secondo te
lo posso disegnare un caso su di noi che
sapeva intervistare di calamaro e
sinceramente non vorrei che secondo noi
vediamo se indovini che disegni
riguardare un cazzo che noioso che segue
o lo faccio piccolo piccolo uno piccolo
piccolo mi sono beccato con gabri
respira l'aria libera mii convinti
veramente un po da rietà non guarda ti
spiego una cosa io quando sei già
sbloccate se qualcosa che non va a
comprare ossia compra in qualsiasi cosa
tutta la chiama anche roba inutile tanto
prodotto facoltà si gioca tra la signora
compra tutto devono essere sempre cose
che dopo cinque minuti non ci buttano ci
fai niente piazza dalla moglie dai
proviamo graduati io non ti porta
occhiali
però ho il naso da mascherina arraffare
guarda questo caso tondo che fai non
l'arrate certo un tale entra multa ma
dove volevi scappare tutti contro
compro tutto un prodotto questo fa bene
l'umore
un prodotto clone sera il doblo così ci
siamo dimenticati questo compro tutto
l'arte del compro tutto poi come
monopoly compro dito contro tutti mentre
compri contro i due caffè compro il
confronto diamo di accessorize speriamo
tutto accessorize ma quelle doveva nelle
cose si compra 9 anche se non è in
vendita nello composto contro lo compri
neanche a dirlo è il carrellino ma la
favola è il contrario 100 200 un po un
prezzo nella vita addirittura compra
tutto la rai un pronto il 30 per cento
questo lo posso comprare 3 19 soltanto
contro una diretta c'è il bel sole
ombrello contro tutto carabini ancora in
vendita
ma che sarà male vedere negozi
soprattutto prodotto guarda come conta
ha sentito il pico ma come ti senti
marco nel compro tutto devo dire bene
anche se non ho idea di cosa abbiamo
comprato neanche a dirlo dove stiamo a
guardare o dietro donald kohn proposto
comprato il top
niente che non sai leggere come entrata
uscita compro tutto metto qui tra le
spade
[Musica]
questo non lo incorniciati come lo è il
mio mai fatto sentire il nostro pezzo
no ragazzi è bravo hai ragione si fa
sentire a prezzo però prodotto da
nessuno
volevo un parere tra con lei
avete veramente tre minuti queste cose
eccoci qua a posto stanno lavorando con
enrico torni subito qui a posto il
microfono di giuliano e microfono di
giuliano ha posto ragazzi mi avrebbe
fatto ho tirato scritto io non so se
rito della loro reazione ha una capacità
[Musica]
terribile eri tu
questo nodo
[Musica]
e appena scalmato la particella ragazzi
posso dire una cosa di strumento serio
oppure dopo questa sapete i pezzi
negramaro non riescono a non stare
sempre in classifica è proprio a loro
che ci siamo ispirati perché la resto
pezzo prego c'è contatto qua dentro c'è
storia
mentre metri o liceo ho sentito pd
mentre finta di non sentire secondo me
l'auto è giusta se non ho la signora c'è
una per pasqua di filiano
mi aspetto che non c è una canzone
d'amore
lì per il thanksgiving è quella lì per
halloween del prossimo anno secondo me
invece a me comunque sembra ti è
piaciuta se non mi è piaciuta invece
sono stati colpiti cioè in senso colpi
compriamo il cappello il caffè comprato
non è all'altezza dei re del
materialismo che intendo io il
materialismo ora si fa sul serio
comprato con prodotto pravato la società
questo interessa affitta loro comprano
premio calcola stai capendo il senso
dello compro un prodotto con produttore
di hotel e guarda che lo teneva hotel
mai tra l'hotel più costoso che ci sia
andiamo compriamolo tempo che stai
facendo per dire di via e avido gabrio
si tratta bene
se brinda stasera puoi anche fare il
turista pervenute suoi vista con alberto
guarda la faro fino al 3 milioni del
nostro case mangia con tutta la recente
esposizione conta cosi comprare cose
contro l'albergo che l'importante non è
contrattare il prezzo è lo compro lo
contro frega un cazzo compro compro
tutto ti senti meglio dover poco lavoro
tutta roba che potresti buttare dopo un
secondo potrei riempire quel vuoto
dentro di te lo compro lo compro compro
ruotolo ripresa mente si versava lo
spumante ha talento è così pochi
contenuti e poi un'altra di mortalità
stato immortalato possiamo fare
pubblicità contabilmente rete
responsabilmente la legge italiana dice
che non bisogna avere alcolici sui sette
se non abbiamo vinto
alla faccia di ieri al nostro nuovo
lavoro
e arrivato il grande giorno guglielmo ti
chiedo scusa
chiudiamo tutti non è nei comuni con un
fatto importantissimo 8 fratello per il
modo di un contratto di assunzione con
me adesso lui fa ufficialmente parte
della nostra produzione cos'hai da dire
al guglielmo dopo questi anni che avete
lavorato insieme ti ringrazio per tutto
quello che mi hai insegnato [ __ ]
vado a lavorare altrove del video sono
ancora andare avanti 6 3 persone ogni
volta lo devono aspettarsi peluso eccoci
qua
andiamo in hotel compiuta nel video
vorrei soldi per la cena mamma mia
la mia carriera artista di strada è già
finita anche da artista è bellissimo e
mi ricordo acciaccata e l'inedito non ci
credo che i maledetti con core camion
cui che cazzo ci voleva prendere questo
passo quello della people
se mi immagino sparito
sommerso di carillon sono rimasto fuori
ragazzi il non visto il tè lasciando qui
o là della via porte a ragazzi tutto
questo con la cacciata di ieri abbiamo
rubato una sedia dalla stanza di lavinia
e l'abbiamo portata qua fatti io sono
pieno di sedie in camera o sono proprio
io che un feticcio per le sedie perché
altrimenti in sé spiega la storia della
mia vita porta sedie porta sede della
uil vrl il babbo natale delle sedie
questa volta che vengo lì e vi ha fatto
sei proprio amore salvatore presti
dobbiamo chiudere solo che andiamo a
rompere le palle album anni facciamo per
graziani fatta valmir iper deve costare
che servizi e camera che cosa volete da
me devi chiudere il libro di un video
questo video è arrivato al suo termine
ci vediamo domani alle 14 freschi così e
su tweet alle 19 che ci vedremo
sicuramente sono installiamo durante il
giorno magari faremo qualche tic toc nel
frattempo se volete riuscire a fare
degli gnocchi con una sinfonia
ciao